[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat dans le monde de
l'éducation l'année 2019 marquer la fin
des séries s es et l
et les élèves qui sont actuellement
seconds seront les premiers à passer en
2021 les épreuves du nouveau
baccalauréat une leur reste d'ailleurs
plus que quelques mois pour choisir
trois spécialités un bac général et
technologique à la carte qui a tendance
à inquiéter les syndicats de professeurs
et les associations de parents d'élèves
pour en débattre ce soir deux invités
elle nicolas bouchard bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes secrétaire du syndicat force
ouvrière des lycées et collèges des
yvelines en face de vous un mathieu wc
bonsoir trésorier adjoint pour la
fédération des conseils de parents
d'élèves des écoles publiques des
yvelines plus communément appelée fcpe à
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
cette invitation et juste avant de
commencer je voulais préciser que nous
avions sollicité le directeur académique
de versailles qui a eu un imprévu de
dernière minute
alors après 25 ans elle est bac
scientifique économique et social et
littéraire disparaissent pour laisser la
place un tronc commun et à des
enseignements de spécialité comme vous
le voyez à l'image les élèves vont
devoir choisir pour la classe de 1ère
trois enseignements de spécialité parmi
12 pour n'en garder que deux en
terminale alors première question toute
simple qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète dans
cette nouvelle formule du baccalauréat
alors ce qui nous inquiète dans cette
nouvelle formule déjà c'est que le fait
que le baccalauréat ne soit plus
nationale tout simplement parce que la
tante du lycée est directement liée à la
réforme du bac qui est directement liée
à parcours sup tout ça fait système
c'est d'ailleurs à l'expression de
monsieur blanc caire le ministre
appartement où le bac n'est plus
nationale
la jeunesse s'est confronté à un
problème de des qualifs il est plus
nationale parce que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
il y avait l'ensemble des bacheliers s
es où elle pouvait prétendre avoir donc
le même bac est donc le même droit à
s'inscrire à l'université c'était le bac
était le premier grade universitaire
avec la mise en place de parcours suppl
il ya désormais une sélection pour
rentrer
universités et dans cette sélection la
capacité à discriminer les différents
bacheliers sur la base des spécialités
qu'ils ont choisi et donc sur la base
des attendus et fameux attendu de
parcours sup qui dépendent d'eux comme
on dirait des spécialités choisies du
lycée dans lequel elles ont été
enseignées des notes puisque c'est un
contrôle continu du cou qui est là qui
évalue voilà donc ça c'est pas un
premier problème est derrière ça est
bien et il ya le fait que c'est une
orientation extrêmement précoce vous
l'avez dit les élèves deux groupes
doivent choisir donc l'espèce les
spécialités de la première donc déjà se
confronter dès la seconde aux attendus
de parcours sup ce qui veut dire que les
erreurs de parcours sont extrêmement
graves alors que dans la formule des
séries
normalement il n'y avait pas
théoriquement de sélection à l'entrée de
l'université et donc avec n'importe quel
bac on pouvait prétendre à une large
gamme de formations universitaires
mathieu et c'est qu'est-ce qui vous
inquiète dans ce nouveau bac au niveau
de laisser peu on était plutôt on est
plutôt en accord avec les objectifs de
la réforme
et puis notamment l'ouverture que ça
peut représenter par rapport aux séries
juste avant par contre ce qui nous
inquiète c'est la mise en oeuvre
pratique
clairement ce une réforme qui a été
précipitée on a une forme d'un
préparation monsieur parler des filières
post bac
on sait pas du tout quelles sont les
attendus on demande aujourd'hui aux
élèves de 2de effectivement de se
positionner par rapport à des attendus
dont on ne sait pas du tout qu est-ce qu
lesquels ils vont être demain avec
effectivement une erreur initiale de soi
qui peut derrière avoir un impact sur la
possibilité ou non pour les élèves de
continuer dans la filière qui serait la
filière de leur choix
alors depuis le 17 janvier l'académie de
versailles a mis en ligne une carte
interactive où l'on peut voir justement
quel spécialiste
quelle spécialité pardon sont enseignés
dans chaque lycée alors en moyenne et
les élèves en tout cas dans les yvelines
auront choix entre huit spécialités à
peu près en moyenne 1 et non et non 12
vous parliez d'inégalités justement tout
à l'heure c'est ce qui est mis en avant
par par plusieurs syndicats
donc vous partagez j'imagine c'est cet
avis le fait qu'on puisse pas finalement
trouvé les mêmes spécialités dans tous
les lycées tout à fait d'ailleurs cette
carte des spécialités elle est
provisoire puisque encore ce matin
j'étais en groupes de travail et il a
été répété par l'administration les
services de la déesse des veines 78 que
les spécialités
actuellement il ya des projets
d'ouverture mais suivant le nombre
d'élèves qui décideront de s'y inscrire
il n'y a aucune garantie que toutes les
spécialités aujourd'hui proposée soit
véritablement ouverte et là où on est le
plus inquiet au delà de ça c'est sûr les
établissements de taille moyenne qui se
retrouvent dans des zones où la densité
démographique et parfois moins élevé et
là il va falloir faire un choix entre un
nombre réduit de spécialités qui peuvent
être maintenus dans l'établissement et
ça veut dire que les élèves qui
fréquentent des établissements de petite
taille et qui n'ont pas le choix dans
leur zone
entre plusieurs lycées à proximité de
leur domicile l'avons eu clairement
avoir un choix moins importante
spécialité que d'autres élèves dans des
zones urbaines plus dense où adam dennis
et plus grands qui propose de base
toutes les spécialités
une problématique sur laquelle on se
rejoint complètement et au delà des
spécialités on a aussi une certaine
appréhension vis à vis des options
notamment des options de langues qui
peut être aussi significatives dans
l'accès à certaines filières ou à
certains métiers demain ensuite
l'administration nous a dit que
potentiellement on pourrait à suivre des
spécialités dans des spécialités qu'ils
ne seraient pas présents dans un lycée
pouvait être suivie dans un autre lycée
du même bassin et là on se heurte à
cette problématique qui rêvait du monde
rural est à peu près la moitié de la
surface de notre département
accédez à des cours dans un autre lycée
quand on est dans la partie urbaine du
département au nord-ouest
ça semble possible quand on est sur la
partie ouest du département très rural
avec seulement de laisser le public
si je ne me trompe pas ça risque d'être
beaucoup plus compliqué pour les enfants
de cette zone avec plus bas l'a
clairement une inégalité territoriale
accuse derrière on peut aussi se poser
la question de l'inégalité sociale de
l'accès entre certains lycées par
rapport à des filières qui sera un petit
peu plus tôt ou alors samedi dernier
avait lieu à versailles à un salon de
l'étudiant y avait notamment de nombreux
élèves en seconde qui étaient présents
ils ont l'art a justement demandé à ce
qu'il pensait de la disparition de ces
fameuses séries tout que ça laisse plus
le choix sur les matières qu'on choisit
nos préférences et
tout ça mieux enfin il y aura quand même
des matières qui vont sauter puis
c'est dans le lycée font pas par exemple
ces matières là c'est enfin moi ça va je
pense qu'il voulait fermer
essayez-vous pas le faire on doit
suspendre sa mort tout ce qu'on veut
faire
- le temps de réfléchir à ce que
ça peut permettre de faire des bacs
d orientation plus précise plus
spécialisée mais d'un côté on
ça peut être à la fois plaidé baissier
ça pourra permettre à certains de tes
pas forcément choisir les mathématiques
déjà puisqu'ils seront plus dans le
tronc commun
je pense que ça peut avoir un avantage
mais aussi un inconvénient parce que moi
je voulais avoir ma petite filière c'est
à dire de toute petite je voulais faire
scientifique et je trouve ça un peu
dommage mais un micro trottoir qui vous
a fait sourire messieurs une petite
réaction
oui parce qu'on voit bien qu'ils ont à
peu près compris tous les problèmes même
si ils sont aussi conscients que ça ils
vont pouvoir éliminer les spécialités
qu'ils aiment pas ou dans lesquels ils
n'ont pas de bonnes notes
et puis ils ont un peu cette illusion
que l'on va pouvoir choisir ce qu'on
veut alors qu'en réalité le choix il
sera quand même très contraint alors
vous êtes professeur en lycée vous
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça va changer
pour vous est ce que justement vous
allez peut-être épauler les élèves dans
leur choix de ses spécialités
ça c'est justement après le volet sur
l'impact sur les personnels donc premier
impact en général c'est que cette
réforme fait de nous des conseillers
d'orientation avec une charge une
pression maximale d'abord parce qu'il
faut qu'on explique aux élèves de
seconde ce qui est le mieux pour eux
sachant qu'on les connaît pas forcément
depuis très longtemps donc on assume
quelque part les erreurs on n'est pas
formé pour être conseiller d'orientation
anormalement les conseils d'orientation
lorsqu'on appelle les copsy qui
maintenant font partie des piscines et
psychologues de l'éducation nationale il
y avait 80 de recruter sur la france
entière l'an dernier cette année 55 ans
est encore en voie d'extinction donc on
voit bien qu'on va remplacer les
conseillers d'orientation par les
enseignants qui sont pas toutes aussi
bien qualifié pour conseiller sur
l'orientation
ça c'est le premier problème général
pour pour tous les enseignants et après
bats pour mon pour ma discipline en
particulier moi je peux par exemple les
séances de travaux pratiques en sciences
de la vie et de la terre on ne sait pas
du tout comment est ce qu'on pourra dé
doubler les effectifs
donc on sait que en tout il faut qu'ils
aient 6h de svt en terminale es et
quatre heures en première s'ils ont
choisi cette spécialité ne sais pas du
tout sur ces heures-là lesquels seront
dédoublés permettront en apprentissage
des sciences expérimentales donc en
travaux pratiques allant des arguments
également mis en avant par le
gouvernement c'est que ce nouvel examen
est censé mieux préparer aux études
supérieures est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cet argument mathieu vcc
c'est tout l'espoir qu'on compte eux
mêmes dans la réforme au niveau de la
fcpe on appelait à quelque chose qui
soit un petit peu plus souple à donner
plus de choix aux étudiants aussi mieux
préparer leurs supérieurs ce serait une
bonne chose maintenant on voit on voit
le cas des enfants qui n'ont pas fait de
choix ou des enfants qu'on fait des
choix qui serait un petit peu qu'ils
seraient pas au niveau sur certaines
matières un de nos questionnements c'est
qu'est ce qu'il en sera de la
romanisation et et du soutien pour ces
enfants est ce qu'ils auront vraiment la
possibilité de suivre les études de leur
choix et pour le coup de réussir dans
les études supérieures ou est-ce qu'on
va les cas les landais faire des classes
avait avec ses enfants sur des
disciplines qu'ils n'auraient pas choisi
alors également dans ce nouveau bac il y
aura moins d'épreuves final y aura plus
de contrôle continu 40% de contrôle
continu c'est vrai qu'on dit souvent que
le bac est associé au stress justement
le fait d'avoir plus de contrôle continu
ou moins d'épreuves final est ce que
finalement ça va pas être finalement
être un examen moins stressant avec
cette nouvelle formule
il sera moins stressant on verra moi ce
que je pressens sait qu'il sera quand
même très stressant à plusieurs moments
de l'année puisqu'il y aura donc si on
ne se trompe pas à quelques quelques
épreuves près 29 épreuves sur le cycle
terminal donc du début de la première
jusqu'à la fin de la terminale donc ça
fait 29 et preuve de stress alors que
jusqu'ici le bac ne s'était pas de 29
épreuves terminales chacune de ces
épreuves donc dès le premier semestre de
premières vont compter donc dans le
contrôle continu pour le bac
ce qui veut dire que nous à la fois
enseignant et évaluateur on sera face à
des élèves qui peuvent à tout moment
dire je ne choisis pas votre spécialité
en terminale et les notes que vous nous
donnez une coupe pour le bac donc soyez
gentil donc sa place ça nous place dans
une situation qui est pas du tout
confortable et sarron le principe
d'anonymat de l'évaluation qui est quand
même propre aux concours oh pardon aux
diplômes républicain qui qu'est le bac
donc du point de vue du stress je suis
pas convaincu qu'il ya moins de stress
et surtout du point de vue de la
progressivité des apprentissages le
principe c'est que l'élève acquiert
normalement
de quoi affronter les épreuves du bac
tout au long de la première et de la
terminale là ce qu'on va lui demander
c'est dès le premier semestre de
première de déjà se confronter à des
épreuves de bac ce qui est pas cohérent
avec le recul nécessaire sur les
connaissances qu'on leur demande d'avoir
en tant que parents d'élèves le fait
qu'il y ait 40 % de contrôle continu
vous en pensez quoi
alors sans aller sur le sur le
pourcentage on voit plutôt de manière
positive le contrôle continu
bon je sais pas si on peut si ça va
vraiment limiter le stress des élèves au
moment des épreuves finales y en aura
quand même les élèves qui seront au
niveau de la moyenne ils seront encore
plus tendue forme au moment des épreuves
finales après rajouter un petit peu de
contrôle continu ça va plutôt dans le
bon sens on voit que c'est un sens de
diplômes qui a été choisi par beaucoup
de nos voisins européens qui leur
réussit plutôt pas mal les modalités
après dans le détail sont effectivement
à discuter
on verra on verra dans le temps si ça
réponde vraiment bien aux objectifs
après une de nos peurs à nous c'est que
ce système de contrôle continu fasse
effectivement des différences entre les
entre les établissements et qu'on se
retrouve à voir des établissements qui
jouent pas le jeu du contrôle national
et qu'ils favorisent leurs élèves
on peut penser que ce soit pas trop le
cas dans le système public mais que
certaines écoles privées puissent jouer
un petit peu dessus et ça vraiment c'est
un point sur lequel on va être très
attentif
cette émission touche déjà à sa fin
merci en tout cas tous les deux d'avoir
été à présent pour ce débat merci
d'avoir suivi à cette émission se
retrouvent mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau 7,8 débat
[Musique]